yeah the chairs just erupting in the
stadium behind me the full-time whistle
was blown and West Ham have won the
Europa conference League beating
Fiorentina 2-1 it was heading to extra
time but then Jared Bowen scored in a
90th minute to seal that 2-1 win and
clinching West Ham's first European
title since 1965 the first trophy of any
sort since 1980 in the FA Cup a huge
night of celebrations West Ham fans
absolutely Delirious the dream has come
true a season when they were fighting
relegation at one point there were
questions over the future of the manager
David Moyes but he's LED this run all
the way through to the Europa conference
League final unbeaten and winning here
in Prague there was a slight stain on
the night in the first half when West
Ham fans did through objects at
fiorentina's Captain it was a warning in
the stadium for them to stop stop they
did their behavior was then impeccable
for the rest of the game and now they
have a wondrous night to celebrate in
East London they are absolutely a
sitting there and I'm sure the party
will go into the night here in Prague
too